good afternoon I want to welcome
everybody my name is Steve Cohen
executive director of the Earth
Institute and I'm happy to introduce
this session today on open data and the
future of funded research as you know
the panelists are going to discuss the
advantages of sharing data openly as
well as the practical implications for
researchers particularly those who work
with confidential information orrow plan
to mine data set for years to come this
is the third of sixth event six events
for this academic year in the research
Without Borders series on issues and
scholarly communication sponsored by the
center for digital research and
scholarship scholarly communication this
program so let me introduce the three
speakers to you beginning immediately on
my right is dr. Robert Chen who is a
director of season the Center for
International Earth Science Information
Network a research unit of the Earth
Institute at Columbia bob is currently
the secretary-general of the Committee
on data for science and technology of
the international council for science
and a member of the ICS you ad hoc
strategic coordination committee on
coordinating committee on it information
and data bob is also the person in the
Earth Institute that we count on to
promote issues of cyber infrastructure
and data sharing throughout the world
seated next to him is John Wilbanks who
is the vice president for science at
Creative Commons where he runs the
science Commons project his background
includes stints at the World Wide Web
Consortium the Harvard Law School and
the US House of Representatives as well
as having been a software entrepreneur
at least you haven't been a hedge fund
trader so that's good and he has a
degree in philosophy from Tulane
University and studied modern letters at
the Sorbonne in Paris but I
understandably speaking to us in english
today so that's that's a good thing and
next to him is dr. Andrew rundle who is
an associate professor of Epidemiology
at the
School of Public Health and he runs
several research projects studying how
built and social environments of the
neighborhoods in New York City influence
health he uses GIS tools to study very
large human health data sets linked to
geospatial and administrative databases
describing the characteristics of New
York City and to a large degree his
research depends on access to data
generated by New York City of government
agencies and so he has an interest in
making sure that that data is a useful
and open so with that let me ask the
panelists to begin and provide you with
them what I'm sure will be those some
spectacular presentations today
gentlemen thank you for the introduction
and thanks to Bob and Catherine and the
libraries for the invitation to speak
today so since I'm going first I'm going
to try to set a little bit of context
for the more detailed stuff that Bob and
Andrew are going to say and the
rationale for data sharing that we work
with science Commons is that data gets
more powerful if it gets linked up to
get too connected this is sort of a
fundamental principle of networks which
is that when you connect things they
tend to get more valuable if they're at
least digital assets but to do for data
what we've done for the web and what
we've done for computers with ethernet
and tcp/ip and HTML takes more
infrastructure than we currently have
and it takes a fair amount of innovation
and this is a great quote about
innovation which I picked up from one of
Larry Lessig's books and it's it's it's
a quote that sort of seems very modern
when you read it and it's about the fact
that people who prosper under an old
regime or typically the people who don't
like innovation to happen and this is
actually a very old quote and it's from
the prince by machiavelli and so
changing the way that established power
structures do things has always been
fairly difficult and there's not much
more in terms of an established power
structure than the scientific funding
infrastructure remember the name
this isn't just open data it's open data
and the future of funded research and
funded research means that for the most
part unlike webpages and internet
servers science and knowledge and data
get created in institutions that get
funded by funding organizations and so
there are different opportunities for
control at each layer of the stack that
don't really operate on the web and on
the network they don't operate on ebay
but they operate on data and the
transformation of data into knowledge
there's actually you've got a great bag
that says without knowledge it's just
data but that transformation tends to
happen in these institutions so how do
you get after changing institutions and
one of the only models we have is
interoperability is a technical
interoperability the way that networks
work is a very good inspiration for what
we want to do with data but in the
beginning technical interoperability is
simply a stack of different technologies
that separate concerns this is what's
called the Semantic Web layer cake it's
an example of the simplest way
supposedly that you could connect data
technically and so it has things like
the markup language that would you would
use whether it's XML or RTF it would
have schemas and query languages and
then you've got sort of this this tiny
little bit up at the top which is trust
which sort of cracks me up that trust is
such a small piece of the cake but this
is sort of a minimum amount of things
you would need to do from a technical
perspective to achieve interoperability
and data and if you are successful there
then you wind up with the semantic
problem which is that computers don't
really understand what anything is
unless we tell them and so I'm making
what I hope is a fair use of a far side
cartoon and so when you know what we say
the dogs and what they hear this is sort
of like what computers here when you
tell them about a data set they sort of
see blah blah blah URL blah blah blah
blink tag they don't know the meaning of
the content in the data set unless we
make it clear and so even if we somehow
magically agreed on the technical stack
we'd have to at some point come to
consensus on what things mean for
computers to begin to hook them together
in the same way that computers hooked
together web pages and servers and one
of the biggest barriers to all of this
is the law which is that the law was
designed
and for copyrighted works of knowledge
for patented works of knowledge for
trademarks that represented brands for
trade secrets it wasn't designed for
this really weird world in which there
were gigabytes and exabytes of data
linked up by computer networks that
wasn't in the Sonny Bono copyright term
extension act in 1995 and in the name
alone should give you a context of who
was driving this it wasn't scholars it
was content companies and so Creative
Commons which is the Oregon work for has
been trying to bring legal
interoperability to the cultural
copyright space and we've had some some
good fortune there and the idea was that
the law should have an interface in the
same way that computer networks have an
interface so if you want a a copyright
license you answer two questions would
you like to allow commercial uses would
you like to allow derivative works and
if you choose to allow derivative works
you can impose a requirement that any
new derivative works be shared the same
way and it creates this set of what we
call human readable licenses so as a
creator you understand what the rights
are that you're giving to your users or
as a user what the rights are that you
have and from a legal experiment this
thing exploded it grew like the network
group and so these are this is data as
of 2008 it's doubled again in 2009
mainly because the addition of Wikipedia
this year to our licenses but what this
sort of shows you more than anything
we're a non-profit everything we do is
free all these legal tools are free but
what it shows you there's sort of a
hunger for interoperability at the legal
level because you sort of want to make
the law go away if what you're doing is
remix in and reusing cultural works and
so we've been looking in the science
part that I work on what are these core
aspects mean in the context of data and
data interoperability because these four
toggles here have almost become code for
sharing in the cultural space but we all
want attribution want credit where
credit is due well non-commercial we all
intuitively know what that is but it's
actually fairly hard to define legally
is it a commercial work if it's a
Columbia University undergraduate
student
in google adwords to pay for her hosting
costs on her blog and she blogged about
science right it's kind of hard to
standardize that in a scalable way this
is hard enough in the cultural space it
gets even harder in the data space and
then things like no derivative works
this might be really interesting if
you're a photographer and you want to
make sure no one takes your photographs
out of context or if your musician and
you want to make sure that the work is
preserved and whole but you do want to
let people make in distribute copies and
then you want to impose some sort of
share like constraint if you say I'm
willing to let Bob make remixes of my
techno music that I make on Garageband
in the plane but he's got to put them
back online under the same licenses now
again when you're dealing with atomic
cultural objects like songs and
photographs it's fairly clean to know
whether or not that right has been
maintained but the law on which this
rests doesn't really work the same way
in the data context and from an
interoperability perspective choice is
actually at odds with interoperability
so this is a chart of our licenses right
against each other licenses that can be
used for derivative work or adaptation
and the green blocks represent
interoperability from a legal
perspective so the public domain is
interoperable with everything you can
add public domain stuff to anything
without constraint attribution is the
only thing that it can't be combined
with is that is essentially is the
public domain you have to basically
anything that goes from public domain
and gets mixed with attribution becomes
an attribution product but when you get
down to attribution non-commercial no
derivatives you can't do anything it's
only interoperable with itself and it
grants no real rights to the users other
than the right to just copy things and
it might be useful to copy a song
because I can listen to it but there's
not much use in copying data if you
can't do something with it my date is
the foundation not the end and this
tension right really is between choice
and interoperability and one of the sort
of great things about the Internet is
that there is no choice if you want to
be on the internet other than to use TCP
or to use IP and these the core
foundational protocols or the network
stack if you want to be on the web you
use
HTML these are open voluntary monopolies
that were achieved without traditional
intellectual property they achieve
because they worked they created the
connectivity and this is the classic
math behind it it's called Metcalfe's
law and the idea is that the value or
the economic value of compatibly
communicating devices grows at the
square of their number and there's
debate over whether it's it's actually
the square or if it's a different
coefficient but there's not a lot of
debate over the fact that connecting
devices into a compatibly communicating
system increases their value and so the
real question of this panel to me is how
do we achieve this for data how do we
make data compatibly communicates that
we can begin to get some of these values
for it and what I think I saw a little
bit of Andrew slides you're going to see
in his slides especially the value of
taking data that wasn't generated for
interoperability with another data set
and munging them together because it
lets you ask questions you couldn't have
asked without those two different data
sets and the designers of each of those
data sets might not have ever intended
them to be combined so the question is
the way the network lets us do this for
devices and for documents we need for
data and so from a legal perspective
which is what we work with for the most
part at creative commons data isn't a
creative work in the eyes of the law at
least in the United States it's
important to realize that free software
licenses free culture licenses work for
the most part because of the existence
of a relatively harmonious relatively
international law which is copyright so
if I give Bob a song and he gives it to
andrew and it was a Britney Spears song
Britney can sue all of us because the
copyright goes with the song wherever we
go in the world now the time and dates
and links of that might change a little
bit with the most part it's relatively
harmonized it's not like that with Dave
so data in the United States for the
most part raw facts of nature are not
considered to be subject to copyright so
like the telephone book is the canonical
legal case in the United States didn't
matter how much time and effort you took
assembling the telephone book addresses
and phone numbers arranged
alphabetically aren't creative
data now in the UK and other English law
countries there is a copyright on data
it's sort of a light copyright and then
the European Union in the mid 90s to
protect their data industry passed a law
that actually created a copyright esque
right on data and it's called a soui
generous law because like the
duck-billed platypus it's right one of a
kind the other laws like this are for
ship hulls and for mask works on micro
processors oddly enough the American
database industry has exploded since the
creation of the EU database directive in
the EU data industry has not which
indicates empirically that the law did
not create the protections it was
supposed to create but what we have then
is is essentially an international
system that's completely fractured which
makes it very hard for scalable networks
of licenses like the Creative Commons
licenses and culture for copyright or
free software to work for data and data
is actually a pretty bad fit for
copyright and so I think visually and
this is basically when you try to hammer
data into a copyright hole you mess up
both the copyright legal aspect of it
and you mess up your data because
creative works which are what copyrights
govern come from the sort of magic right
of the author where you lift your hand
from the paper and the copyright
attaches to the paper to this
presentation I don't have to register a
copyright for it and the copyright was
going to last 70 years after I died
that's how far into the future
copyrights go in order to protect
creative works like Mickey Mouse and
other systems remember Sonny Bono
copyright term extension act not you
know Albert Einstein copyright term
extension act and so think about the
aspect of having 70 years of prevention
of copying of data after the death of
the scientist who created now the other
weird thing about this international
regime is that you might create at some
place where there's a copyright but if I
get a copy of it and republish it in a
place like the united states where there
isn't one unlike the britney spears case
you can't come after the person who
downloads it from the United States and
if I can prove i got it from a US server
than the odds are pretty good that I'm
in the clear and so that makes licensing
things hard and so let's go through the
creative commons terms since these are
shorthand for sure
let's look at them one by one so non
commercial again this makes a lot of
sense of your musician you want to post
a song you don't want Ford to put it
into a car commercial you put it on
lender non-commercial license but what's
a commercial use of linked data this
would be sort of saying well if someone
at Pfizer runs a google query is that a
commercial use of the web and if we're
going to have a link data web if we're
going to have andrews epidemiological
data coming online we're going to have
bob's climate change data coming online
is it a commercial use if someone who
gets paid to look at data runs a query
against it is it a commercial use if
they make a copy for research use
locally at their company is it a
commercial uses a startup uses it in
order to make a decision about whether
or not to go forward with the project
this sort of constraint on data in the
early stages actually is pretty toxic to
data interoperability and if you think
back to the web's early days and the
Internet's early days there were no such
constraints so when the web was released
Tim berners-lee made the code public
domain didn't patent the process that he
went through and then he basically
enabled widespread copying through view
and edit source and in the early days of
the internet again widespread copying
was how the internet began and
constraints on who's allowed to do that
actually would have been pretty toxic so
non-commercial we looked at that we said
we can't use those terms share alike
this is typically called copyleft it's
the idea of imposing the idea that if
you're going to share the next person
needs to share as well and this is the
key idea behind free software licensing
and this is the the icon if you think
about there's a lot of different things
that are not really consonant with
something like share like so privacy is
completely incompatible with share like
changing data formats linked data
scientific norms national laws so
whatever you do and I matter how much
you try to sort of mash licensing terms
like like copyleft with data you can
make an emulsion out of oil and water
but they don't ever truly mix and that's
what you find when you deal with share
like and data as well and once we had a
group that gave us this is an exam
this is jon snow's cholera map from
london in the 1800s and this was one of
the earliest examples of Epidemiology so
i've got it up in honor of andrew and
the modern version of this so these are
the this is a street map and then the
dots are deaths and the x's are well
heads and it was able to it was sort of
the core of convincing them that collar
was actually water transmitted the
modern version of this would take a
street map database as opposed to an
actual picture of streets and it would
take clinical study data about disease
incidences in a neighborhood that
disease data carries what's called HIPAA
or privacy constraints and if the street
map data carry is a copyleft constraint
then you can't put the two together
because copyleft systems typically say
you cannot combine data with this data
that can't also be released under
copyleft that's how most of those terms
work and the existing data licenses that
attempt to impose copyleft style systems
have had to deal with this through some
systems that where you have a choice
either the copyleft works and it's viral
and it forces people to be open or it
actually doesn't get reached through an
enforcement it allows interoperability
you don't really have the ability to
sort of force people to be open and data
because you don't have that big powerful
right and even attribution gets
complicated so this is something that
intuitively we think citation and credit
where it's due this ought to be scalable
but in the web world so this is one page
of attribution for Wikipedia and so each
of these is a name and they're an
incredibly tiny font and the most
current print out required 27 pages of
attribution like this so again project
this out 10 20 30 40 50 years because
it's built on copyright any one person
can bring it down with an injunction if
they feel that they're not being
attributed properly that's not a very
stable infrastructure for a long-term
web and again in a large cultural work
like Wikipedia where we have a copyright
system which is relatively harmonious
and international we can mitigate some
of these things but in data we don't
really know what it looks like because
copyright and data are such a bad fit
and even worse is what if you simply use
something
linking to it you haven't copied it so
you haven't triggered any copyright
licenses and what you find is it over
and over again when you deal with this
that you can't meet the expectations for
data that have been generated for
software and for culture which is the
expectation that you can force people to
behave nicely through the law and it's
going to relatively cheap for you to do
that that's a power that comes from
copyright that we just don't really have
in data so what we've been doing is
working on the public domain as the
substrate for data we have this thing
that we can with a very sexy title for
which is the protocol for implementing
open access to data and the whole idea
behind this is interoperability of
scientific data and the idea is no law
rather than free long the idea is that
you want first to waive all of the
rights that are necessary for extraction
and reuse so there are copyright things
that attach to pieces of databases like
the way they look and the way that you
load data in so you need to wave those
so that your user doesn't have to figure
out where the copyright stops and starts
you don't impose obligations even ones
that would in theory make it more free
to limit downstream use because in the
beginning of a web any friction is too
much friction and the way to deal with
this is to request behavior through
norms so the human genome is our example
here the human genome is in the public
domain and the scientist who participate
in the projects related to the Human
Genome Project use norms to guarantee
compliance and behavior as opposed to
the law and this is something that's not
particularly controversial in the big
sciences at least yet so this is an
article an opinion piece from nature and
September that came out and endorsed the
public domain approach and we're seeing
it adopted by more and more open science
approaches so this is the tropical
disease initiative it's a kernel of
drugs that bind to disease targets for
rare and neglected tropical diseases
this data is in the public domain the
Personal Genome Project which is going
to take a hundred thousand genomes
Health interviews and sets of stem cells
and make them available with the minimal
sets of constraints in the public domain
being picked up relatively quickly we
now see a BitTorrent network
work for massive genome files being
transmitted around under the licenses
they were wary of using the data
previously because they didn't know
where the rights stopped and started and
even in Europe where the database
directive is very popular from a freedom
quote unquote perspective this is a
beginning of waving those rights in
order to preserve interoperability this
is from the european molecular biology
lab and sort of sub most surprisingly is
that companies in the united states like
Merck have begun to adopt this approach
so Merck looks at this and says well
they put terabytes of gene data into the
public domain in the 90s and it actually
had two beneficial effects one is it
created a standard around the way the
gene data was organized and that helped
us from a technical perspective but it
also kept bad patents from being issued
by creating a lot of prior art so Merck
is taking the entire disease biology
platform they spent a decade building
moving it into a nonprofit organization
which is putting globally coherent data
including intermediate traits variation
clinical trades and basically putting it
all into the public domain as well as
the software needed to make that data
into disease models and so sage is the
nonprofit that's doing this and the
whole idea is that no matter what deals
the organization does to stay funded
everything they do moves from left to
right so the data moves into a public
domain the code moves into a free
software repository and all the
documentation required moves under a CC
license so the companies are sort of
figuring this out in many ways faster
than the scientists are they don't have
the same barriers to change and funding
in many ways and then sort of most
relevant to to Bob here is that he's
been part of pulling us into this thing
called the polar information Commons
which is a global repository of
information about the poles from a
climate perspective and this is a big
international if you see all the
acronyms down here at the bottom and all
the logos and when you want to actually
integrate that information it's much
easier to say that we're going to use
ethics and norms to do that instead of
the law because otherwise bringing
together the laws of all of the various
countries and the lawyers from all the
various institutions is almost np-hard
right getting lawyers to agree on single
basic standard
tracks for things even to give them away
is really really complicated so we've
been very proud that the polar community
has done this as well so with that I'm
about done and I just wanted to sort of
take this back from Merton who's a
famous sociologist of science and I
think it's an important principle that
we go back to because again it's very
easy to fall into the trap of having our
thinking guided by free software and
free culture which starts with private
property creating property through its
licensing and in science it's a little
different and it's always been the case
that you create property in science by
giving property away that's how you buy
a place for enlightening other people by
publishing your knowledge that's how you
get credit for it and so we have to
think about that as the first principle
as we move into open data systems and
simply get the law out of the way using
the public domain because the models
that we have for culture and software if
we port them in they might have
unintended consequences that don't give
us sort of freedom and openness that we
want thank you
so I followed her I've seen John talk
and I know it's hard to follow his kind
of presentation it's very polished and
crisp so we'll see and it's nice that he
gave me several segways that I'll get to
I kind of changed my title around
because when I was thinking about it
it's really about together open data and
research as a as a package and I'm going
to step back a little bit also and not
just come from where John's coming from
but go back to a little bit of this
ethics and norms issues which has come
up in a few contacts one is something
called the world summit on the
information society and and a few other
activities all mentioned so one of the
foundations I guess of thinking about
this is the universal declaration of
human rights in which you know buried in
article 27 is this idea that science you
know the products of science should be
shared by all it's not it is property
but the benefit is giving it away and
having it benefit everyone and that's
been taken up by this international body
called the international council for
science which is a international
organization with members of all the
Academies of Sciences of countries and
they have a statute which talks about
the equitable access to data information
and research materials and this is
something that you know our US Academy
has bought into as as representing the
scientific community here and the idea
of it was based partly in the Cold War
and other areas when scientists didn't
always weren't allowed to communicate
but the scientists scientific community
and
stood on free exchange and interaction
but it carries over i think into the
modern age now talking about digital
digital divides between north and south
and so for the developed countries who
are members of the organization for
economic cooperation and development
it's actually a very interesting
document that came out two years ago
called the principles and guidelines for
access to research data from public
funding and this was a effort really to
establish a norm that if you're getting
taxpayer money is a researcher you
really have an obligation to make your
data and results available openly and
the first principle was is this openness
which is you know not necessarily free
access but but open access to scientific
results and it actually goes on and says
you know you can't just hide it can be
open but hidden somewhere it should be
easy to get to on the internet and so
forth all these documents are online I
have a copy of the OECD principles here
and actually janja showed one of the
papers from this issue of of nature and
their particular editorial which really
is part of a slow process of recognition
of the need to open up access to data
this was a editorial that the president
of code eight and I published a few
years back in conjunction with the world
summit but you know trying again not
legislating not legal but trying to set
the expectation in science to open up
access to worry about the digital divide
and tech data and technology transfer
and so forth so that's sort of the basis
of coming at it from science you know
the next thing I thought is important to
say is is why is it important and I
think it was mentioned this is
co-sponsored with the Earth Institute
this symposium so I'm going to talk
about it from the Earth Institute
perspective you know it kind of goes
without saying that
climate change is a pressing issue and
this is data from our which was partly
developed by the Goddard Institute for
Space Studies just down the block
looking at how in fact climate change is
already happening we don't have to
predict it it's actually been observed
to occur and have substantial impacts
already if you look at the polar data
it's just amazing how much has been
happening the lowest sea ice extent
occurred two years ago in 2007 and
there's 2009's not quite as bad but it's
still it's still low this is something
you can monitor on the National snow and
ice data center website and if you look
at places like Greenland they also has
had much wider melting than in the past
over the last couple of decades I could
go on forever but you know it's
happening in Antarctic it's happening in
mountain glaciers around the world clear
signals in the cryosphere and the study
that was alluded to looks at data from
the cryosphere from the ecological
systems from terrestrial and marine area
showing you know evidence of climate
change already happening and of course
leading to the idea that it's going to
continue happening and of course there
are lots of other reasons why we need to
share data hazards are still pretty
deadly emerging infectious diseases all
sorts of problems for which sharing of
data is really vital so one thing that's
happening is
lots of people are investing a lot in
collecting more data so hundreds of
satellites in planning nASA has a whole
new set of missions plan for the next
decade or two lots of data being
collected but in the traditional mode
all very stove-piped so you know a
country or a company or whatever
collects the data to sell or to make
available to it their own researchers
not necessarily share and so there is an
international initiative called the goop
on earth observations which is trying to
develop a unified global system
something they call g oz still under
development not really there yet but
it's an effort to get the stove pipes to
interoperate of course the initial focus
has always been on the technical
interoperability all different formats
ways of collecting data continuity
issues different types of data that are
difficult to integrate both remote
sensing satellite and GIS and surface
observations and so forth all trying to
be put into one system so there's a big
technical problem but of course in
reality one of the sleeper we have
problems is the one that John's talked
about how do you actually get these data
to work together from a legal and
institutional viewpoint because again
not all countries are like the u.s. just
says all the data we collect is in the
public domain in fact they're not only
are their countries like the
Commonwealth ones that have copyright
but there are a lot of public private
hybrids we're just the tiniest bit of
private money put into what is ninety
percent tax payer suddenly makes it
basically the province of private
property and you know that's a really
unfortunate situation actually the
university does that too we see that
here
me and elsewhere we're just you know
it's federally funded but we put in five
percent from a private source so
therefore we control it and we don't
have to open it up so that's you know on
the basis of it not very fair let alone
ethical I don't think so within geo
there's a set of data sharing principles
that were established up front and
they're kind of good they call full and
open exchange of data but the fine print
does say you know recognizing relevant
international instruments and national
policies and legislation so it's always
a fine print of legal documents that
kill you right so one of the efforts
that I've been involved in is to develop
implementation guidelines for these
general principles and now one of the
points was really sure there are
reasonable and necessary exceptions
protecting indigenous peoples protecting
endangered species confidentiality and
so forth but you want the exceptions to
be exceptions not huge things that you
know everybody uses to get around what
is ostensibly open so we've been
involved there was a paper that was just
my first paper ever with three other
lawyers that came out in the Journal of
space law and data science journal of
about two months ago and that's the
basis for a set of proposed guidelines
that are actually now in the purview of
the international past data sharing Task
Force which is meeting next week and
along with the plenary so I mentioned a
lot of polar data because we're also
involved with as John mentioned the
polar community of some of you may have
heard about something called
International polar year which example
Robin Bell here at the Earth Institute
helped help get off the ground the
actual field measurement phase ended in
two thousand earlier in 2008 or actually
earlier this year but they're actually
in the process of still working with all
the data and the big issue in some sense
is what's happening to the data and so
you know they had agreed on a policy to
make the data shared among all the
different science groups both social and
natural scientists but you know making
that practical and figuring out what
happens after this this intensive
research period is still up in the air
so in that sense this is where the polar
information Commons initiative comes
from two stepping back if you look at
the Antarctic Treaty which is actually
in its 50th anniversaries coming up and
that established a legal physical real
Commons for the continent and as part of
that treaty there were articles that
referred to first of all free scientific
investigation open scientific
investigation hardik with a compulsion
agreed to buy all the signatory nations
about 48 or something of them but they
would share the results of their
research coming from this stuff I'm
coming that research about the physical
Commons would be shared it openly so
there's a at least the legal basis for
thinking about virtual information
Commons matching the real Commons Arctic
is a little more complicated it's there
eight countries that have territorial
claims on the entire Arctic region
there's a debate about things like what
happens if there's no Arctic ice cap
anymore
group that I've been dealing with that
well there was a paper I figured it was
nature or science in which there was the
idea that we should concession should be
considered open ocean and therefore law
of the sea and the traditional body of
law that applies to the open oceans
should apply but it is actually a big
legal debate but whether or not it's a
legal comments one of the issues is is
there still a basis for our shared
information Commons that is focused on
the scientific data and knowledge that's
necessary because not only because it's
in the mutual interests of the eight
parties but it's because it's in the
mutual interest of everyone in the world
given that the Arctic is important to
our climate and other thing so that's
one of the bases bases or this polar
information Commons initiative what we
want is to establish or or make the
claim that these are public goods the
data about the poles or public goods
that they ought to be shared and that we
need both the institutional legal
framework as well as a technical
framework to enable sharing of data and
that we really need to take the internet
model that's developed John alluded to
of a really collective you know
grassroots ability to to put effort and
time and resources in to creating this
without putting a lot of legal and other
constraints on it so we have adopted we
went through a whole process and we have
adopted the science Commons protocol
we've been working with John and Caitlin
thainee from science Commons we have
we're in the process developing what we
call a badge pic badge to signify to
people digitally that data is part of
the polar Commons and in the distributed
internet that data can sit anywhere but
as long as it's labeled it's part of a
verge of virtual whatever collection
that people can see as if it were in one
place but it's not
and a set of community norms so I think
she showed that from the web page yeah
so there's a draft that's sitting on the
web page and we've just kind of created
and are vetting with some of the
co-ordinating organizations and then
we're trying to vet that with a broader
community and it refers to things like
what do we expect users to do when they
use big data and what do we expect
contributors to do when they put data in
you know reasonable citation know if
you're using 5,000 data sets in some
analysis do you you know we're not
expecting you to cite five thousand
individual little bits of data from all
those sources but if you're using it in
the way most scientists site data and a
publication yeah you should but you
don't have to because it's not a legal
requirement I won't go into too much but
one of the things that I think
interesting from the library view point
is that we feel that one of the barriers
to preservation of polar data is that
the archives and the infrastructure that
is looking out and saying well what's
important it what's useful data if they
actually have to go and secure the data
and get the rights of the data from all
those individuals it's a very intensive
effort but if the community is made the
data available whatever form wherever it
is it actually makes it much easier for
archives to go out and mine and look and
say well you know if I got that data and
integrated it with this larger
collection it would make every the
original data and the collective
resource much more valuable for
everybody so they can just do that
because it can find it through the pic
badge they can know the rights through
the CC waiver or or CC by license and
they can use it and do it without having
to do too much consultation and that's
important because you know data sources
disappear they change the authors die
they lose track of things so having the
right up front to use data makes the
archiving I'm sorry the appraisal and
selection
and hopefully the curation process much
more doable from the viewpoint of you
know the institutions and groups that
are interested in polar data stewardship
so you know just to kind of sum up
science clearly is important and
sustainable development is is very much
need science to help resolve the many
challenges out there open access has a
lot of potential benefits for research
and for data you know just looking at
the need for interdisciplinary work for
making more rapid progress you know not
having it locked up for 70 years and so
forth it should read reduce duplication
of efforts and in fact that's actually
one of the drivers for research funders
to actually want to invest in this type
of approach because what they see is a
lot of duplication when data is locked
up and not shared and broader community
participation I mean I think one of the
amazing things about looking at the
Creative Commons experiences is the
people from outside the traditional
community come in and contribute and do
stuff then put in labor and develop code
and so forth and scientists there are a
lot of examples of participatory science
but this is one where you could imagine
even more applications just because
people like polar bears are or are
interested in the topic or whatever and
again as I mentioned it's an opportunity
to open up the stewardship problem and
it eliminate at least one of the
barriers to to the long term stewardship
and preservation issue so thanks
appreciate your thinking about this
good afternoon and thank you for coming
out and thank you for inviting me I'm
going to describe their research efforts
of my group as a way of illustrating the
issues we face with open data and what
you're going to hear is much more
chaotic and idiosyncratic and
disorganized data issues and anything
that my two colleagues have presented
which have been efforts to sort of have
organization and principles and what
we're encountering is in many ways the
opposite of that and so a lot of what I
do is consider how neighborhoods
influence the health of their residents
and how the characteristics of
neighborhoods influence the health and
we're working with this notion of the
built environment which has been defined
by niehs as all building spaces and
products are created modified by people
it includes home schools workplaces
parks and recreation areas greenways
business areas and transportation
systems it includes land-use planning
and policies that impact our communities
in urban rural and suburban areas and so
it's both the physical that exists and
it is the policies that will someday
make the physical exist that constitute
this notion of built environment in new
york city basically New York City is
nothing but built environment we have a
few nature preserves but otherwise
everything in New York City has been
built even the parks have been built and
so what my team is doing we're
investigating whether differences in the
built and the social environment
characteristics of neighborhoods impacts
the health of the residents of the
neighborhoods and so what we do on a
very very large scale is is simply this
we have study subjects from research
studies where we know something about
where they live and then we describe
their neighborhoods and so this is a map
of northern manhattan and i live at 100
overlook terrace and the orange box
around my address is my census tract and
that strange polygon that's in yellow
around my house is all the space that i
can walk to in a half mile walk along
network and so we use that as a working
definition of a neighborhood and we have
a study in which we have 13,000 study
subjects and we have generated these
definitions and neighborhoods for every
single study subject obviously this
relies on access to a GIS layer of a
street map so that I can figure out how
far I could walk and a half mile and
then we want to describe the
characteristics of that neighborhood so
you see a few other stars there 605 Fort
Washington is my grocery store so that's
why I buy my fruits and vegetables it's
handy that that's close to my house 806
West 187th street is my local bar that I
like to go after work and have a few
drinks and that may be stress relieving
and health positive or alcohol inducing
health- 180 fourth street in Fort
Washington is my subway stop so I walk
there every day that's a 10-minute walk
is about mmm maybe about 100 calories i
extend getting there I have to climb for
stairs and four sets of steps that
increases my physical activity and so
these are just a few descriptives of my
neighborhood we intensely describe these
neighborhoods and we do it for 13,000
study subjects we're just going online
with a study of New York City children
that's going to have 600,000 children in
it and we're going to describe every
single neighborhood around every single
child and we rely on administrative data
to fill in the information about
neighborhoods and so we use GIS as a
framework for linking all kinds of
disparate data sets together through
longitude and latitude and so we
retrieve information from your
governmental sources commercial
databases and field surveys and our
perspective is that anything that is
licensed regulated inspected find or
under the purview of New York see
government information about that must
exist in a database so if I want to know
where the elevators are all elevators
are inspected every year that means it
must be a database somewhere that tells
the inspector where the elevator is
therefore I can get that database
theoretically and know which buildings
of elevators and so we take this basic
idea and trying
utilize that to find data that we can
use to describe neighborhoods and we
have human data that we've collected
through epidemiology studies or through
Department of Health Studies through
their administrative data sets and we
use the GIS system to create metrics
about what a study subjects neighborhood
looks like and so we do a lot of work on
obesity and I'll show you a several
slides from the obesity research and we
work with several notions key notions
about neighborhoods one is walkability
the idea is it's a set of urban design
characteristics that promotes pedestrian
activity so that's physical activity and
provides a means where you don't need a
private automobile so driving a car is
essentially sedentary behavior you burn
very very few counter calories in the
car so if you could be car independent
you're going to be more physically
active obviously we're interested in the
food environment availability of fast
food supermarkets fruit and vegetable
markets we're interested in the
recreational environment you know access
and quality of parks and ball fields the
availability of commercial recreation
exercise facilities and so we've done a
number of studies looking at how the
characteristics of neighborhoods
influence the obesity or the BMI of
their residents and so we have a study
of 13,000 individuals and we've been
working with this idea of walkability
and we wanted to come up with a metric
of access to public transit and so here
you see a graph of increasing access to
public transit and the average BMI of
our study subjects this is nice downward
trend it represents about a one and a
half one of the third BMI units which
spread out over the population of New
York City would radically change the
obesity epidemic in New York City if you
subtracted about one of the third BMI
units and so our metric of access to
public transit is the census variable
the percent of the population commuting
by public transit and so we can easily
down that a load that from the Census
Bureau without any problems we can
create neighborhood measures that tell
us how many people in each neighborhood
use public transit here's a similar
graph looking at access to supermarkets
produce markets and health
stores and what you see again is this
trend of down would be mi with
increasing access to healthy food
outlets and this works out to be about
three quarters of a BMI unit across the
range and in trying to get the data to
describe where supermarkets are this
data is kept by different departments in
city government and in do H and working
with all of those departments to try and
find out where the fast-food was where
the fruit vegetable markets were was
very very difficult it's so difficult in
the end that we actually just bought a
commercial database for thirty thousand
dollars that is used for marketing
purposes but tells us where all the
businesses are in New York City and so
we ended up instead of just getting data
that should have been available from the
city government spending a lot of money
to buy the data and this information is
now actually underlying changes in the
zoning in New York City so there are
neighborhoods New York City where you
cannot buy fresh fruits and vegetables
there are no produce markets there's no
supermarkets there's no grocery stores
and so they're changing the zoning to
make it easier for supermarkets and
produce markets to open up in these
neighborhoods like in central Brooklyn
where you get candy fried chicken but
you can't buy a banana and so this these
results are being used as part of the
scientific basis for changing parts of
the zoning regulation here's a similar
graph in which we looked at our same
health food healthy food sources data
and we combined it with data from
200,000 New York City births in 2001 and
what we're looking at is the odds of
maternal obesity and what you see is as
the number of healthy food sources
increases the odds of maternal obesity
significantly decreases and this data is
this graph relies on data from the
Department of Health's vital statistics
and so the Department of Health
maintains information on all deaths and
all births and it for births it
maintains information on whether the
birth was a premature whether the mother
had Medicaid whether the mother had a
pre prenatal clinic visits and it
data on the mothers wait for years and
years and years this kind of data was
not accessible to public health
researchers the doah had it but they had
it under lock and key and so for the
years the mailman School of Public
Health could not access fundamental
basic public health data about New York
City because voh would not share it with
us we've recently brokered an agreement
whereby we will have access to vinyl
statistics data which underlies this
graph which underlies the paper that we
were publishing which is going to
underlie the changes to the zoning to
make it easier for people to get fruits
and vegetables and so I kind of see this
as a win but it took years to get access
to just fundamental basic public health
statistics we've been looking at the
availability of Park since this is a map
of all the parkland in New York City
it's twenty-nine thousand acres it's 40
fourteen percent of New York City we
wanted to look at the quality and
location of park so we wanted to know if
being near a park and being near a high
quality park was associated with more
physical activity and obesity and New
York's the Department of Parks has the
GIS data that tells you where all that
parks are but it also maintains quality
metrics they inspect all of the parks
and look at the quality of the parkland
for garbage and litter and weeds whether
or not the playgrounds are safe all this
incredibly important data for
understanding why somebody would use a
park and here's the same old graph that
I show with my red dots and here we have
a very modest association it's
statistically significant it's only
about of a third of a BMI unit and this
represents the percentage of land within
a half mile of the study subjects home
that is actually parkland and so this is
a rough estimate of how easy it is for
somebody to get to a park and to get
this data from the parks department they
were really friendly to us for many many
months before they gave us the data so i
had to give multiple presentations to
the parks department about exactly
we would use the data I had to go out in
the field and actually participate in
the data collection process so i would
understand how the data were collected I
then had to sign a series of legal
agreements specifying what we would do
with the data and then I had to give the
lawyer five dollars and then I signed an
agreement in my own name to get the data
and now we have it we have beautiful
data about the parks but it was a
probably 18-month process to get
information of just where are the parks
in New York City I have colleagues in
San Diego's in around San Diego them
actually even have data on where the
parks are like nobody's even collected
information where the parks are so at
least in New York City we have beautiful
crisp data that with work you can get
access to this is my last example we've
been studying childhood asthma and
street trees so New York City has a
census of street trees the idea is if a
tree falls in the city somebody's got to
go pick it up and plant a new tree so I
need to know where the trees are so here
we've combined data on asthma prevalence
from do H with a density of street trees
and what we found is that across
neighborhoods in New York City a 1
standard deviation increase in trees is
associated with a twenty three percent
lower prevalence of asthma and so New
York City is about to plant a million
new trees on the streets and so this
kind of information is very helpful for
them in thinking about where they going
to plant trees the u.s. Forest Service
has just given us a big grant to really
study why it is that trees may prevent
asthma and so we actually have a
partnership with Department of Health
and the Department of Forestry in New
York City to study foliage and trees and
how that might change air pollution
levels of the microclimate and how that
might influence asthma and little
children but you know to underlie this
we had to find we had to discover there
was in fact a Department of Forestry in
New York City and then reach an
agreement with them to give us the data
on the location of all trees they
wouldn't actually even give us the
location these application of the trees
and we just tell us the number of trees
on each block for some reason the actual
location
of the trees in our initial in our
initial relationship was not something
that was gonna be available to us since
then we have a much better working
relationship with them and we are now
allowed to know not only the location of
the trees but the width of the tree and
the gender of the tree and so by
combining these sort of administrative
data sets are being collected routinely
by city agencies combining them with
health data we can start to understand
how neighborhood characteristics affect
health in the city and this kind of data
is then fed back to city agencies who
are making all kinds of planning
decisions about how to improve the city
we provide them this sort of clues as to
how they can improve public health
through these kind of data analysis so
the issue here in terms of open data is
how to get access to administrative data
sets like this and there is no in my
experience systemic response across the
city agencies so sometimes it's just a
simple download at one point I wanted to
know where all of the sidewalk cafes
were in New York City it turns out that
the agency that licenses sidewalk cafes
have a excel spreadsheet on their
website you can just download it so that
was super simple sometimes it turns out
that Columbia already has a license for
the data and so Jeremiah who is one of
the GIS librarians can help us with
getting a data set through the existing
licensure that Columbia already has
sometimes is a handshake deal with just
an agency official you meet a guy or a
woman in their office you vaguely
described what you want to do you shake
hands that you're not going to do
something with the data that is going to
make life difficult for the agency and
they hand you a cd-rom sometimes you
have to sign data usage agreements
really onerous data usage agreements
that colombia's a council office has to
get involved in and can take months and
months we are once told first we have to
build a relationship and then we can
sign a license and so we spend a couple
of years building a relationship with an
agency having my students work in the
agency explain them what we wanted to do
we had to build this relationship first
sometimes we're told foil us do a
freedom of information
direct request because we can't really
give you the data without having
somebody in the agency get angry but if
you foil us that will give us cover to
give you the data and sometimes we just
get the stiff arm no way no how are you
getting this data and so the primary
example of that is the police department
so if you do surveys of parents asking
why they don't let their children go out
to the parks or the playgrounds the
number one response is it's dangerous in
my neighborhood there's a lot of crime
and so we want to test whether or not
crime has got an influence on physical
activities that we want crime statistics
from the police department to match up
with our human subjects and for years
and years and years the police
department has refused to give us even
just you know at the track level of the
zip code the number of crimes and it's
been continuous blockage on that and
getting this data often comes down to my
team sitting around saying you know I
know a guy I met a guy at a conference
you know had drinks with a guy who knows
a guy in that agency maybe they can
provide us with some kind of in it's
completely not systematic and this is
data that's collected with our tax
dollars and there's no systematic way to
go about accessing it and it's an
enormous burden to negotiate these kinds
of agreements and keep track of all of
the licensing arrangements that you've
negotiated to get your hands on this
data and then once you have the data
there's this issue of what is my
responsibility as the researcher to
further disseminate this data to other
research groups and there's two types of
data there's the raw data and then
there's the valid value added
measurements that I have created from
that raw data that represent the
creative manipulation of data or the
layering of multiple data units together
to generate a value added measure and
some of our data usage agreements
prohibited this flat out say we cannot
further share this data with anybody on
the other hand what is my incentive as a
faculty member at Columbia to share data
with a competing research
yeah this data forms the basis of my
research programs my grant applications
and my publications which translates
into promotions in tenure for myself and
for my colleagues who work with me so
what is my motivation to share the data
that I've created or licensed or spent
days and days they schmoozing to get
with another research group you know
when I went out for my last promotion we
talked about my publications my teaching
record never once did anybody suggest to
me that you know i would get credit for
depositing data in the library or
sharing the data with another research
group it's not part of the reward
structure under which we're operating
and so it's this disincentive for me to
share it and then once i do share it cuz
i often actually do share my data with
other research groups managing and
monitoring how that information is
disseminated is a huge burden is it
being used within the structures of the
licensing agreement that i originally
signed is it being used within the
confines of the agreement i have with
the other researcher for they're going
to use the data for and so we spend an
awful lot of time just sort of managing
the flow of information that we've
created to other groups and i recently
had the i recently found out that I had
given data that we had created from sort
of value-added measures to another
institution to work on a project we
wrote a nice paper together it was a
great relationship and then later on
other researchers at the institution I
guess came across text describing the
data and the fact that it was on their
hard drives wrote a grant proposal
saying they were going to use these
measures and this data subsequently got
the grant proposal and then called us up
and said all right so can we have that
data you have and could you tell us how
to use it and what you do with it and
I'm on the phone going what and so the
question is is there some central role
at columbia for kind of managing this
kind of administrative geospatial data
in an organized manner because it
moment you know it's not chaos but it's
really disorganized and it's slowing
down research and this is the kind of
research that actually the city then
uses to set policy make decisions so
this is like real world public health
where we find something out and an
agency makes a change you know to make
fruits and vegetables available and so
this is slowing things down and I don't
know what the solution is but I've been
talking to people the population center
here at Columbia about maybe they should
have a role in sort of managing and
coordinating all of this flow of data
that we've been amassing over the last
six or seven years and so those are my
thoughts about this and this is what
I've described here is a lot less
organized than what my colleagues here
have been working towards and maybe you
know up in the public health school were
far behind what they've achieved but now
we're facing these issues and kind of
like looking for solutions on how to
make this data open and usable without
there being also data anarchy of
everybody doing the same thing so thank
you for your attention okay so maybe I
could focus and also generalize from two
other things from something you discuss
actually in the first talk so in the
first talk you made passing reference to
code and in particular two different
licenses on code so there were some
reference to GPL BSD etc is Creative
Commons advocating that code should also
be distributed under CC 0 you know code
when your scientific when you're a
computational scientists code is sort of
like the apparatus that you build it is
also the blueprints for how that
apparatus works and more and more so
every year sort of publishing in four
pages or six pages is woefully
inadequate for actually describing what
you did so again code was not in the
title of this session so I'm sorry for
generalizing to code but since you
brought it up maybe you could discuss a
bit about how the panelists in general
and also Creative Commons thinks about
how code should be distributed also
funding agencies was in the title so
I'm curious to know what the three of
you think funding agencies should be
doing for example right now the policy
of funding agencies is play nice so
we're going to give you the dollar now
under the understanding that after I
give you the dollar in six months or 12
months you'll be nice and there's
absolutely no mechanism for enforcing
that some of the agencies don't even say
that so I'd be curious to know your
thoughts about code and how it relates
to what you're discussing the first doc
and also what funding agencies should be
doing differently to help us all thanks
so the if I could have a theme it would
be use the right tool for the right job
so free software licenses work really
well for software and so we tend to
recommend that you use a software
license for software so we have a
research fellow at science Commons in
Victoria stodden who's working on what
we call the reproducible research
standard and essentially the idea is
that we would provide a trademark like a
quality brand mark that you could use if
you are a computational researcher and
to get that you would use you would say
your code is under an open-source
Institute approved software license your
documentation is available under an open
content copyright license and your data
is in the public domain and that's
that's to need for the legal
reproducibility constraint and then
ideally there would be some element of
annotation you would have to have as
well so we would not say to put your
software code under CC 0 and wave the
rights we would actually say use a
software license and so the reason we
recommend using a data tool for data is
the same reason we recommend using a
software tool for software is that sort
of like separation concerns on the
internet you want to use the right tool
in terms of funding agencies what we've
seen is that the funders have the most
leverage to change the system as well as
the institution's Andrew raised a great
point which is that you never get asked
for your data impact factor you don't
get judged on the use in the utility of
the systems you create you get judged on
these sort of knowledge artifacts that
you create and the NIH moving to force
open access to the literature that it
funds is one step the NIH for most
projects over a certain funding level
requires a data sharing plan but then
the data sharing plans are
not part of the peer review process so
it's it is a it's a it's a it's a little
bit more like play nice but the bigger
the science the more likely it is that
sharing is mandated and what's
interesting from what andrew is talking
about is this is an end of this is a
small group of people hacking away and
trying to come up with it there's no
infrastructure to then republish the
data the way we have for the human
genome or the polar information Commons
and so the systems that we've built that
work work at the big levels not at the
small levels and that's why we keep
talking about the network as a as a
metaphor which is the network enables
everyone to help their computers up to
the internet not just large institutions
with giant mainframe computers and so we
want a system that allows the polar
information Commons but also allows
Andrew to set up a population sharing
system well just like a quick thing on
the second point agencies are taking
notice NSF is thinking about more
stringent data requirements they've
always had a data plan paragraph you're
supposed to put in there but seems
rarely enforced but I think because of
the actually the OECD document is
percolating down this efficiency
arguments are percolating down and and
so that you are going to see actually
more requirements another big area that
you know you can spend a whole nother
whole panel on is is well two issues is
first of all persistent identification
of data you know in order to have a
citation in a you know like a
publication but for data one problem is
you know how do you label it what's how
do you do versioning how do you find it
so there are a lot of people
experimenting with persistent
identifiers and and related to that is
people discussing how do you change the
promotion criteria so that if you have
you know unique data sets to your credit
you you can you know count those as if
they were a publication or something but
then you need a whole quality review
process structure that's comparable to a
scientific paper and you need you know
systematic ways at least within defined
fields for the community to come
together and agree that that's really a
valuable contribution and so forth so a
lot of discussions about this in
different fields you know different
levels of progress in doing those sorts
of things and you know maybe over a
decade or so will will get there I
discussed or mentioned or advocated
sharing of the geospatial data that I
have it's never really been discussed
and we've been operating basically on
your play nice idea and so I share the
geospatial data I have with people I
work with people who seem like they're
good people you know there's no like
rigorous criteria robert wood johnson
which funds a lot of health research is
actually further ahead i think on this
idea and so they've been pushing
standardization of data and
centralization and sharing of data so
that we can do a study of New York City
San Francisco book Vancouver and had the
same types of data shared across cities
that we can do cross city studies but my
NIH program officers really haven't ever
discussed this to us the last speaker
could you continue the story you are
asked to provide data to somebody who'd
written a funded proposal I just like to
hear the end of the story the story
hasn't ended I had a series of meetings
coming up I've had a meeting to express
the unacceptable nature of this and i
have a meeting coming up to come to a
solution whereby I mean the project that
they're going to do is actually really
great but a way of going about you know
being a colleague was not so great and
so I want the project to go forward
because I think it would be very useful
but we need a way to work together
whereby there's some there's an
equitable relationship so you wish to
execute a degree of control I don't know
if I want to execute a degree of control
but the
the things they promised to do aren't
legal under the licenses for the data I
have and so I can't actually give up the
data so the kinds of information they
want have to be generated at Columbia by
people of my team who are allowed to
generate that kind of information and in
that the raw data can't be moved but the
derived variables can be moved but you
know they're now basically saying my
team has to invest a lot of time and
energy and percent effort to generate
variables so we're going to find a way
to go forward make that happen right but
it's not this is not a system that is
sustainable for the next ten ro ones
that go in our next ten research
projects that go in I hesitate to ask
this question with Jeremiah right next
to me but I just want to pick up on your
issue about a centralized place at
Columbia to manage
like the days of yore creating
provenance over the data so it's very
hard to publish a paper where you
explain how somebody at some agency gave
use of data and that's the end of the
description we need to have a trail of
like the problems of how the information
was created the agency level what year
it represents what parts the city a
represents it has to have all this
metadata associated with it that
basically described its problems because
next year that we know the data sent by
the agency right and so the management
of all of that kind of information is
very labor-intensive and not something
anybody on my team was ever trained to
do there's none of us were trained in
library Sciences right and so that's
part of it secondly the maintenance of
the licensing agreements and what you're
allowed and not allowed to do with the
data who's allowed and not allowed to
see it is something that also we were as
a researcher never trained to do I'm
sure there are professionals out there
who were trying to do that and so very
few okay and so those just two of the
big things that consumed a lot of time
and energy that take us away from doing
health and research that could I think
way more efficiently
some kind of organized structures
systematic way essentially well just I
mean there's really two parts of the
problem I think that you're alluding to
there was is actually a responsibility
by the city agencies to do the data
management and the metadata preparation
that you think should be there and
obviously isn't you know we've our
centers done work with Chris corns and
it at do H where they have a group
that's supposed to learn how to do the
metadata and and you know properly do it
obviously they don't have the resources
or whatever to do completely to enable
sharing of data even within the city
which you would think would be a
interest of the city and and of course
doesn't help anyone else if they don't
do it themselves I think what you know
one of the things that John alluded to
is just this power of being able to have
digital rights management that's
embedded in these licenses is one of the
big things that you know is we have to
look to the future so that you don't
take you know me you know cadres of paid
professionals who know how to do this
that the machines know how to do it you
can program against it you can do your
mashups you know without worrying about
it I mean without ignoring it which is
the way it's done mostly but but with it
properly taken care of and so you know
evolving the digital rights
infrastructure i think is a really
important need to enable open access and
research that you know some groups are
investing in John and John in particular
can probably say a lot more about their
well I mean we have a narrative
publishing industry and tradition in
science that goes back to 1665 so it's
your philosophical transactions of the
royal society
and that's where citations come from and
so you have author title journal volume
page and you can get to in any library
that has that journal you can get to the
article and so you have the the
publishers talk about registration of an
idea but by sort of stamping the date on
to a text certification of the idea
through peer review dissemination
through subscriptions and then
preservation of the records through this
idea of the citation and so those four
functions can be performed weekly by the
internet and that's fine in the cultural
world but in a citation world when you
really want to know you know did this
data come from johns public health blog
or did it come from the city right
because that's actually going to affect
it if you want to extend it john's
molecular biology blog is not as
trustable as Columbia Medical Center and
so the ability to view that provenance
and understand what it means is one
thing the ability to have preserved
through multiple copies of the data is
the second thing and there is no
industry or tradition that exists to do
that because the capability economically
and technically didn't exist until ten
years ago I mean if you downloaded a
song in 1998 when iTunes first came out
you remember how painful it was compared
to today so the ability to just
physically move bits this this quickly
as new and there's no culture and so
we've been trying to argue that the
libraries of the natural institutions to
play that role because you know science
Commons how many nonprofits are around
for more than 50 years the Red Cross how
many companies are around for more than
50 years how many government agents in
yeah my buddy remember remember the War
Department right
there's this there's going to be some
workshops coming up that nature and some
other folks like the digital curation
Center and Scotland are going to be
hosting on what does it mean to site
into a network data model there are some
things we can look at from the cultural
web like track back pain which we can
think about it's a track back as an
extensible technical protocol it lets
you say I basically I quoted you in a
blog but you can make it directional and
contextual and you can say essentially I
tracked back to your data set because I
used it and I built derived variables on
tracked back to it because my algorithm
hit it a track factor because it's crap
which is actually a really important
thing to know whether or not you're
linking to something because it's good
or because it's bad right and so getting
through that sorts of experimentation is
where we have to go before we expect the
library to actually maintain a
meaningful institutional resource but
the librarians have to be willing to
engage in that not thinking themselves
just as containers of knowledge but they
actually play a role is sort of similar
to being a librarian 200 years ago which
is where you help them you help the
search or get out into the world one of
one of the things I've noticed not not
to disparage anyone but one of the
things I've noticed in the culture of
the GIS world is very free sharing of
data sets and so it almost seems to me
you get a couple of geographers in a
room and they start trading memory
sticks and so I have really interesting
and amazing data that has come to us
that are never ever going to use for a
look at because I have no idea how we
got it where it came from where that
person got it wrong but there is seems
to be this culture in the geography
maybe but what as an epidemiologist I've
noticed it where there's a lot of
trading back and forth of data
test and that's not usable in an
academic world because I could never
site it I don't know where it came from
under the quality of it and so that also
might be a role for libraries as the
authenticator in some manner of that
kind of data